بم بم تي
[موسيقى]
في في منزل انثى الارنب دقه دقه الباب في
منزل انثى الارنب دقه دقه
الباب من الباب افتحوا لي انا ت ساقس
عليكم حتوته افتحوا لي فقط الباب لا لن
نفتح باب الدار نعرف ف الذئب الغدار ماما
قالت الا نفتح ابدا ابدا مهما
صار في منزل انثى الارنب دق دق الباب في
منزل انثى الارنب دق دق
الباب من بالباب جئت انا جرتكم مرمر
لتعروني بعض السكر افتحوا لي هيا الباب لا
لن نفتح باب الدار نعرفك الذئب الغدار
ماما قالت الا نفتح ابدا ابدا مهما صار لا
لا لا في منزل انثى الارنب دق دق الباب في
منزل انثى الارنب دق دق
الباب من بالباب انا قرد الغابه ميمون من
يدخلني له بالون افتحوا لي هيا الباب لا
لن نفتح باب الدار نعرفك الذئب الغدار
ماما قالت الا نفتح ابدا ابدا مهما
ار في منزل انثى الارنب دق دق الباب في
منزل انثى الارنب دق دقه
الباب من بالباب انا ارنوب اكل جزر ذو
الفائده يقوي النظر افتحوا لي يا اصحاب
اهلا ب ماذا تريد بلقائك انا جد سعيد يا
غدار انا انصحك ان تجري الان لبعيد
يا
ويلي